why do covet variants keep getting more
transmissible this chart shows how
infectious different versions are
compared to the original strain of the
covet 19 virus look how much better
omicron and its successors are at
spreading in relation to variants
earlier in the pandemic
two main factors are giving the virus an
advantage in its race to infect how
contagious it is and whether our own
defenses tip the scales we'll also go
over what all that means for our
prospect of getting off the covet
variant treadmill
let's start with how much better the
virus is getting at infecting and
spreading one of the most important
factors is its innate contagiousness
during the pandemic variants of gain
mutations that have made it easier for
them to spread among people some have
helped the variants bind to cells and
then enter them many of these changes
have sprung up in the spike protein a
structure on the surface of the virus
that helps it attach to and enter our
cells earlier in the pandemic that alone
could give a variant a significant
advantage the better a variant is at
attaching the more likely it will enter
the cell to make copies of itself but as
we've developed antibodies and other
immune defenses that's put pressure on
the virus to evolve and mutate in ways
that allow it to evade antibodies
which brings us to immune evasion so
let's go back to that chart again
omicron was roughly six times more
transmissible than the original strain
of coping it had more than 50 mutations
with about 30 in its spike protein alone
some of those that made it easier for
omicron to get into cells but other
mutations made it more difficult for
antibodies to bind to the virus which is
what keeps it from getting into cells
that viral combination especially immune
evasion is what made omicron more
transmissible and that's what drove last
winter's spike in infections if a
variant is more effective at spreading
either because of increased
infectiousness better immune evasion or
both it can outcompete other variants
and become the dominant one again that's
what happened with omicron and then with
ba2 which was almost nine times as
transmissible as the original strain of
covet that's to be expected that's what
viruses do they hone their genetics to
become better at spreading for instance
some studies suggest that ba5 one of the
latest omicron subvariants has mutated
further to evade antibodies increasing
its chance of escaping them
so does that mean we're doomed no
scientists say they do expect to
continue to see variants that are more
transmissible and that outcompete
previous versions of the virus and more
cases can mean more deaths some experts
think there are limits to how much the
virus can mutate because too many
changes could actually prevent it from
getting into cells it's kind of like if
you bend a key too much it won't fit in
its lock anymore but how good of an
immunivator it can become is a different
story as new variants infect us we gain
immunity plus our prior immune defenses
can still protect us but to a lower
degree vaccine makers are also making
updated shots that are tailored to new
variants in august the uk became the
first country to approve a coveted
vaccine targeting omicron and other
countries like the us are likely to
follow we're probably going to see more
vaccine updates as we continue to
coexist with the virus if you're
interested in just how infectious
omicron is and how it changed the course
of the pandemic check out this video i
made and see you next time
[Music]